cold wind chills this morning things are
bouncing around thanks to some very
strong north winds
and these started picking up overnight
at the airport we've already had gusts
over 35 miles an hour wind chills easily
in the low 30s around the valley today
and it's all behind a cold front
which is pushing through the desert
right now
so again temperatures are in the 40s but
it feels much colder and it will be all
day
snow is pushing through the plains and
across the east here comes that cold
air miami looking at 60s right now but
again by christmas day
they're going to have morning lows in
the 30s so falling iguanas in florida
they're on alert windy conditions with
wind
advisories southern and eastern clark
county those start
here in just about 10 minutes we're
looking at 7 a.m start time
for wind advisories 56 for us today
that's down
quite a bit from yesterday's nice 70
degrees
it won't be 70 for christmas day as we
look ahead
to our christmas forecast 58 and mostly
sunny skies
we'll have a nice christmas day and
it'll feel like it should for christmas
uh temperatures will warm up as we get
into the weekend just slightly
62 by saturday and then we'll look for a
slight chance of some showers on monday
our last monday of 2020. nothing too
dramatic nate